[Musique]
pour son dernier jour de visite à la
réunion le ministre de l'éducation et de
la jeunesse Papen DIY s'est rendue sur
la commune de Saint-Paul pour inaugurer
le collège rockfeuille aux côtés du
président du Département Cyril Melchior
chers
pour moi
d'inaugurer avec vous le collège
roquefort
chaque année la collectivité
départementale consacre 41 millions
d'euros pour la gestion l'entretien
l'aménagement la réhabilitation et la
construction des collèges
vous savez ce n'est pas anodin que
d'inaugurer un collège en métropole
construit plus de collège vu l'évolution
démographique et à la Réunion le collège
Roquefeuille c'est un des derniers
grands collèges que le département aura
conçu parce que la coupe démographique
le démonte on en a plus besoin forcément
on va passer à beaucoup de
réhabilitations d'anciens collèges mais
conçoit de nouveaux collèges
c'est peut-être un des derniers pas le
dernier il y en aura encore un ou deux
mais après on va passer à la
réhabilitation c'est pour ça que c'est
un événement important c'est en présence
de tous les élèves de l'établissement
ainsi que des parents qui a été dévoilé
la plaque inaugurale
les collégiens ont ensuite fait visiter
l'établissement au ministre un collège
moderne et innovant
la journée s'est terminée au collège
elyvisel du chaudron où ont été abordés
les thèmes de l'illettrisme et du
décrochage scolaire
[Musique]